he uh do i start yes okay you're
listening to the dollop on the all fang
comedy network this is a bye
um
come on buddy pedal no american it's
actually not even a it's actually just a
weekly podcast i don't think you need to
say it anymore it's poc actually it
would make a lot of sense to drop it so
just say it's a weekly podcast three two
and actually this is a weekly podcast
no i'm confused of course
uh it's about american history my name
is dave and i do it with oh my god
gareth reynolds and i don't know what
the topic is about
so
because through me man
absolutely one last buy perfectly for
like 400 episodes now the intro is to
you my look nailing it i get to complain
about the preposition ending but i don't
care but your beef is you've gone
you're like you you're like you you
treat the injury like jazz you're like
we'll find it baby thank you let's go
out there and we'll find it together
okay so you notice i'm doing jazz not in
a bad way like i'm doing yeah but you're
doing jazz like during a rock session so
it's like you like nobody wants nobody
wants that person it's like nobody needs
that person it's like you doing a
podcast with monk right thelonious monk
you're over here
we're jamming and i'm
by the way look i'm i'm sorry i don't
mean to i'm not trying to pull any age
card you can't say monk to me and think
that i'm going to go to thelonious first
i go to tony shalhoub
the ocd investigation that's why i said
by the
it's a lot closer to doing a podcast
with tony shalhoub than it is
i saw your face alone
very confused very confused i was like
okay i guess it i mean you do look you
you're shalum ask i suppose if you
really want the compliment i didn't know
i'd have to say this the first name but
i did because you oh mug he doesn't
felonious monk goes by thelonious monk
monk goes by monk
i can't believe i've said monk so many
times it's less all purpose and meaning
i'm the [ __ ] hippo guy dave okay my
name's gary my name's gary wait is it
for fun and this is not gonna become the
tickling podcast okay this is like adam
on a five-part confession
now hit him with the puppy
you both present sick arguments no sleep
down hippo
now it's over a lot of dead air at the
end of it it looks like no it's over
read your stoops okie dokie hey
everybody it's gareth from the dollar
podcast
[Laughter]
do you like to laugh gosh i do and if
you do come join me on the road for some
live stand-up comedy new york times
calling me the best comedian ever of all
time um
that's uh two weeks ago um december 2nd
through the 4th this coming weekend i'll
be in appleton wisconsin at the skyline
comedy club then sunday december 5th
this weekend sunday i will be in chicago
illinois at the den theater then i will
be december 17th i'll be at the white
rabbit in indianapolis then i'll be in
fort wayne in the tiger room on december
18th december 19th i'll be in somerville
massachusetts at the crystal ballroom
that's a sunday and then i'll be
new year's weekend i'll be at the comedy
club of kansas city december 30th
through january 1st let's ring in this
new exciting year together
go to garethreynolds.com for information
oh i love that i love that too i love
that you love that uh yeah thank you
um
so i'm gonna do an antioxidant wait hold
on let's also say december 10th we'll be
at the observatory in san diego doing
our last live dollop of the year
and there's a good chance that pam
reynolds might be there oh
so
and her favorite son
um oh uh your brother's gonna be there
um
no that's the truth
aaron's laughing this is so like yeah
is that real
so i'm gonna do an anti-ad okay
um went on uh
you know thanksgiving vacation with some
relatives uh
i'd never i haven't rented an airbnb in
ages i just stopped doing it a while ago
because we had bad experiences
but
it was like there was it was like the
cheapest and best thing you know i
rented a very nice place sure and um
and i was like oh there's a good deal
now i didn't know
how bad airbnb can be but it's not
really airbnb that's the problem here
so as soon as i
made the reservation
that popped up vicasa
so vacasa is another company
v-a-c-c-a-s-a
sure and they
own properties and then they rent them
through airbnb and it's the model that's
what we that's how it should be should
we go you should be
be double and triple renting through
people absolutely no
so um
now our plane was delayed
as they are four hours so that's a
spirit for you yes at the time our uh
plane is supposed to land
i get a text and a call from picasa
that our condo
is not available sure
and is this this to you is uh
problematic yeah because that's where
i'm actually staying sure and they offer
us two
uh separate versions two separate places
that are nowhere near as good like just
shitty shitty kid can live alone for a
week that's right yeah so just shitty
comparisons and they're like these are
what we can offer you for the same price
and i'm like you know well that's
obviously not acceptable um
i call airbnb and airbnb he's like yeah
we'll look into it
so we're [ __ ] okay right basically
we're just [ __ ] we paid a lot of money
for this place we're not getting it
uh turns out they do this constantly
vicasa vicasa sure
an airbnb does not allow you to put a
review on a site
if you've been canceled an hour before
you're supposed to check in weird
so uh
my sister actually looked into it she
was furious she was on the emails and
she found um
a scientist a scientist looked at the
data
and i'm not crazy about this scenario
already he's this is what he said the
most common airbnb scam the host offers
a nice accommodation for a good price
unbeknownst to the guest the property
was listed more than once
on airbnb and potentially other
short-term rental platforms
once at a cheaper rate and once at a
much higher rate if the host has a new
guest
make a booking at the higher rate they
cancel the guests who booked at the
lower rate usually last minute
but that's not what happened to us
that's one of their scams because i went
to the place
you went to where you of course you did
you went to where you were where they
canceled yeah this is what they said
they said they said this is my house you
are an are you i just want to look at it
they said uh
they said well there's construction
going on and i said well how long did
you know that construction was going on
could you not have told me yesterday
or the day before it before that was
supposed to be done this morning i said
so why are you calling me at 3 p.m
if it was not done this morning yeah oh
whatever so i go to the place the entire
building's got it oh my god the entire
building is gutted the enti plastic over
everything the balconies
it's being completely redone and
it hasn't had a person in it for months
there's no recourse
so what do you get you get your money
back airbnb gave me my money back and
i'm still like and uh you have to figure
out where you're gonna live yeah well
then you have to spend more money right
so there you should use airbnb
but picasa is the main and they clearly
work together but vicasa is this company
that runs out tons of and here's the
thing i said to my sister and she goes
this is what happened to us in lake
tahoe five years ago we had a family
reunion
we went through vikasa
we go to the house it's [ __ ] canceled
it's amazing it's it's a sex in the hat
and then we stay in the shittier place
it was the exact same [ __ ] thing five
i just didn't remember it
so this company that's what this company
does vacasa does this so you're telling
people don't stay the [ __ ] away from
vicasa if airbnb if you rent to play
some airbnb and it says you know jimmy's
going to rent it and also it's vikasa
it's a [ __ ] scam get the [ __ ] out
sure get the [ __ ] out run run from
vicasa run okay well i think that's good
aaron did you learn something
okay good all right good um
well that sounds fun yeah that's cool it
was fun we also dave have to remind
people that we have a live virtual show
i just remembered
december 16th we have a live virtual
show that we're doing with moment house
we're very excited about we will be
doing uh
it at 6 p.m pacific time you can go to
momenthouse.com
the dollop to get tickets
but it's going to be one of those ones
you know where we've got a bunch of
pictures and videos and dave does it
shirtless and um
and all that stuff so
join us for that december 16th and we're
calling it uh go big and stay home
that's what we're calling it so go big
and stay home
december 16th 6 p.m pacific time
go big go big and stay home and stay
because of the situation we find
ourselves in oh
because things are fine the new uh the
new variant's called american that's
right american
best best brilliant yet
i got it worst thing that happened to me
was i got stars and bars across my heart
i'm dying from loving america all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
put my ipad like this so i don't have to
hold it
this is that this is how jesus christ
wanted speaking of jesus christ june 15
year
of you can say it you can say it i mean
he was
our lord jesus yes christ christ satan
spanish
all right lord jesus christ though good
well done thanks it's for everybody it's
the worst thank you again it's not jazz
it's jet i'm jet this whole [ __ ] show
is just starting 30 minutes in you know
we should actually redo
the logo and say the dollop and then
jazz like like in a miami like in a
miami vice lighter episode
dolores mccord
was born in new orleans louisiana the
name again edward and
edward we're going to change she'll
it'll be more english is
at least that's what i was told
someone's going to say that's wrong yeah
that's what i was told it's idiots her
mother marie was a
super good looking
mixed-race woman okay she was french
creole okay her father real for those of
you that's correct
her father was a very respected uh
shopkeeper not not doing that well with
the shop he was a free black man okay
named where are we are we in new orleans
we're in new orleans
they love when people do that they do
that they do that um named uh his father
august theodore was her father she had
one brother and one sister they're
raised catholic
although
um at one point uh she said she was born
in uh bordeaux france as marie rachel
adelaide de ver spencer okay
wait so she is like
she's like i don't love the name of dua
i guess not so and she's she's so she's
this is again i mean always good how old
is she she's young oh she's young but
later on she would we're talking about
her past so later on she would say she
was also
born in france right okay and her name
was marie rachel chevrolet de vere
spencer sure yep close yeah original if
you're gonna make up a name make it
yeah nice sounds like she's working with
monk yeah
uh
adelaide celebrate oh yeah
i tried to hit it but thank you aaron
that did deserve a spotlight oh [ __ ] you
dave and she said after france she was
raised in cuba for a while and then then
the family moved to new orleans she also
said she was born to a french woman and
a spanish jewish man her name was
dolores adua
los fiertes but another writer said she
was born adam accord in memphis the
daughter of an irish merchant and his
wife catherine
in that version her dad died and her
mother remarried and then they moved to
new orleans the truth is her father was
august and her mother was marie so the
version you've told us is the real one
but she there's a lot of embellishing
and to me that's not a red flag i've
carved out four different lives at the
end of your life that to me seems fine i
mean i haven't told you this but i'm
actually uh i'm living a couple other
lives
uh doing a couple other i have two other
careers what's your other all comedians
what's your names
uh well i do smashy uh-huh smashy the
fruit man which is where i have a fruit
stand i didn't know that was it it's a
very offensive italian uh situation
i mean i don't want to do it so i walk
up and i go may i have no you're not on
stage no i'm doing the whole thing and i
have a little cart and i watch up and
then you say if you walk on the stage
security again this is a structure from
the audience i see me i have a banana
sir
i i mean again that's that would be
considered heckling but i go a banana
what is it with this guy and i'd smash a
melon okay yeah yeah i do that one um
and then i have another guy who uh is
another comedian too who's that that's
magic joseph okay yeah and uh that's
comedy and magic which i really love
doing it's a lot of dove stuff i love
dove yeah it's a lot of dove stuff and
um yeah so what do you need stuff like
what
i kill a lot of the same thing as the
italian guy up smashing doves oh jesus
same thing
like just take them out of a hat or
something or
no they basically come out of a barrel
you know there's there's jammed in a
barrel there's 30 of them in a barrel
can they fly well i mean they could i
don't allow it you know and by the end
they definitely can't none of them can
this sounds less like magic and just
more like a barbarism sort of horrible
it's all done with curtains and do you
get an audience huh
is there an audience that comes to this
absolutely how many how many people i
don't let's get back to the story
come on focus
so um
her father uh died when
one i found some people that said seven
other people said when she was a baby
okay um
so marie then sold the shop and moved
into a boarding house a bordeaux a
bordeaux house and that's where she met
and married dr j.c campbell who was the
chief surgeon of the us army okay
so he's a chief sure
she raised ada now she's been called ada
okay
uh he raised he raises data as his own
child sure he's very generous he
encourages it's a real low bar for
fathers who come into this situation
like he treats her like his actual
daughter it's like okay that seems like
fair what do you should be doing as
opposed to a stranger
don't touch me touch your mom you ain't
come from me
this thing's just blinking [ __ ] as far as
i'm concerned every day she comes in a
nightmare every day she comes out who
the [ __ ] is this
oh here we go again let me guess you
need something i just wanted some water
oh my god it's all it never ends
drink from the toilet like the dog i
wanted daddy
you're still here huh i live here jesus
ugh christ
gonna drink in the morning again have a
banana no
somebody say a banana there he is
uh so he's very generous he encourages
her many talents but she has many
talents she's a writer a painter an
actress a dancer
and he pushes her to learn different
languages so she speaks french and
spanish sure
she studied the classics she read poetry
he got her dancing and horseback riding
by the time ada was 11 she had several
poems published
what yeah she's [ __ ] true yeah okay
she's she's a [ __ ] she's a good poet
she's a good poet she just i mean she
just becomes a horrible liar that's
right right
she then danced in the ballet of the
french opera house in new orleans okay
her relationship with her mother not as
good all right
uh
aydah wrote her sister describing how
much her mother disliked her
okay it's a cool letter yeah that's cool
uh apparently your mother was jealous
it's also that was like therapy back
then oh yeah right well hopefully i hear
from her someday until then i'll just
live in the darkness
that'll be fine
apparently your mother was jealous of
all the attention campbell gave to aydah
oh my god that to me is the worst
situation too yeah yeah yeah where like
a kid is just like but i was just trying
to be cool that's like shut up i just
wanted a dad you're not my daughter and
you're not my daughter either
the guy who doesn't like her the mother
is jealous of no he doesn't all right
sorry i've invented that part
now it's like talking to my mom
uh so you're there to prod me back nope
yeah
you made that up sir oh did i oh right
that's all right
uh so in turn she's not treating her own
daughter well and ada is dreaming of
better life
and then her stepdaughter died and her
stepfather dies in uh 1852. she's 13.
okay
so she's crushed she's totally destroyed
she had relied on his encouragement and
his support some people said that he was
kind of an absent father to her
yeah i had heard that um
i heard an improv guy say that so just
so you know yeah a couple camps okay
well i mean that one's real and then
one's just something some was almost
written i don't think we need to get
facts
about whether or not this guy was good
let's keep going but uh
uh so the family's destitute um aydah
has to work as a language tutor she says
i can't catch if i can just get my next
poem published
now she's a little uh she's a little uh
ahead of the time she kept a diary and
she wrote in it quote
she's 17 at this point
the one the woman of today is not
a slave but free so she's saying like
right you know
time to take off the chains and
be
be aggressive and get out there yeah so
like we shouldn't put up with this [ __ ]
right i was not a prevailing attitude
at the time especially for a 17 year old
right yeah her mother uh didn't take
long to remarry
this time to a man who actually made
improper advances toward aydah and her
sister
and finally aydah couldn't take any more
and she left home oh my god that's just
good times you really want to vet these
step five i mean if you marry three
one's gonna do it yeah you got a dud
yeah you know he's gonna find a shimp
uh so
she hooks up with a local troupe of
entertainers sure
in
october 1853 an austrian noble mm-hmm
baron frederick von herberstadt thank
you for this okay so this man comes in
on a chandelier obviously
edna
holding his uh the leash of his tiger
yeah
what do you think huh
uh he asked her to come with him to
havana
sure uh listen
if an austrian baron with a tiger asks
you to go anywhere you gotta yeah
uh she had tutored his daughter that's
how he that's how he knew her okay in
havana
she was apparently she says yes
obviously yeah she's like yeah for sure
she was apparently his mistress in
havana okay
and she performed for the well-off uh
she danced the audiences loved her
uh she says she was called queen of the
plaza while she was there is that okay
now
an actor horace keane wrote quote
scarcely 16
so the age obviously but scarcity 16 she
overwhelmed the audience with her charm
and talent her tiny frame
crisp black curls and dark sparkling
eyes made her a beauty unlike any that
have entertained her before
is it any here before is it any wonder
havana is bewitched by her
what is she doing at the show she's just
kind of like dancing yeah she's dancing
it's a she's a ballet dancer she's dance
so she's dancing okay she must be really
good and she's smoking she's really
attractive she's smoking a lot yeah
right so they're like wow i didn't know
i loved dance i don't think to deal with
pal
i don't think it's dance i love the way
the breasts move i love the ballet
oh look at the bottom
um could she stop moving so much and
just stand
is there a dance called jiggling please
so
now this
at this point in her life there's
different versions of what happened so
another uh
version the so the
the baron bailed on her sure and this is
on encyclopedia.com she
some believe she then survived as a sex
worker to get by for a little while okay
and then she got back to the us in 1856.
wow okay
[ __ ] barons a [ __ ] barren i would
just you never want to put your fate in
a bearing ever ever if a dude has a
tiger on a leash you're out it's hard
though it is i mean i just i i would
even even knowing that i'll be destitute
and doing sex work i'd still be like
it's the maybe tiger that's a baron yeah
it's pretty good it's a lot of good
there's a lot of good yeah it's gonna be
good sexing no that's not necessarily
where i was baron's all i'm more into
the tiger like rhinos yeah as you know
what yeah i spend some time never mind
after uh after he bails on her
she does that then she gets back to the
u.s and her fellow entertainers tell her
she she goes back to you know her troop
or whatever right and they tell that she
can make money as an actress okay um so
she quits dancing in the ballet and goes
all for acting she's all in okay
um difficult because always a good call
by the way oh yeah acting is when people
are like i'm going to narrow it down to
acting you're like that's going to be
fruitful yeah no you should learn
landscaping also yep
uh it was so it's difficult because she
is mixed race sure the theater owners
who knew of her background refused to
hire what year are we in sorry roughly
we're in the 1850s oh jesus okay yeah
right uh so
so this is probably where all the
stories of her childhood came from as
she uses them in the moment to you know
finagle any situation right okay
interesting but it also makes her seem
mysterious and that helps her get work
so it's all it's a whole thing
whatever it's just so the entertainment
business has always just been absurdly
done it's just [ __ ] dumb as [ __ ] well
now that we don't know your history
we're interested in working with you
yeah it's weird that you lied to us we
like it
so she makes her way to liberty texas
where she worked as an actress which
i mean this was just when they just said
theaters all over the place because
there's nothing else to do right
so uh she would give public readings of
shakespeare she also wrote newspaper
articles and she wrote poems and she
taught dance classes
but it was a lot
so she decided she needed a wealthy
husband who could support her acting
career so she's looking for a sugar dad
sure
so she put an ad in liberty gazette
seeking a husband
okay which is crazy to see i mean it's a
weird look at that i think i'm gonna
marry this girl
so there i was just looking for a
refrigerator i think i found my wife
look at this she sounds wonderful hello
i'm interested in your ad about getting
married to you i understand you're young
tell me what you are and what you look
like and who what you like i am a woman
i'm ready to sign anything i have
i don't need to hear any more details i
have hair i like what i'm hearing don't
talk past the clothes though and i you
don't i listen enough i'm waiting for
some red flags you have hair eyes and or
a woman e gads
all i've got is this cooling box that
i'm buying from the paper i have all my
parts uh lady enough
there's probably some things i should
tell you
like i don't have a bottom half okay and
uh or
i'm not i'm more of i'm not
i am more of a animal man than a man
okay i'm what they call uh a humanzie
half chimp half human oh
now
are you rich yeah i have a lot okay
great
this is a good match
my wife my husband it became
weird-looking
look at all your hair yeah it's
everywhere
rash
was that common
i don't know
i mean she she definitely does stuff
that is not common so i don't know okay
i tried to figure it out basically
started the bachelorette i mean it seems
like yeah she yeah i mean
she did she started all that [ __ ] i
guess let's say that let's say she's the
first
on this episode okay uh this is november
12th 1855 this appeared uh sorry
november 23rd quote i'm young and free
the pride of girls with hazel eyes and
nut brown curls
they say i'm not void of beauty i love
my friends and respect my duty i've had
many full uh
boo ideal bow ideal
yet never
never found one real there must be one i
know somewhere in all this
circum ambient air
and i should add's going on a lot by the
way when you're talking about the air
it's like yeah she's just crossing per
letter she's just trying to rhyme really
hard right okay and i should dearly love
to see him now what if you should chance
to be him
so this dude reads it just one well i'm
sure a lot dude yeah i would imagine
there were i'm sure they printed her a
dress too
there's just a bunch of horny weirdos
like i'm in i got no questions
so this traveling well-off uh a musical
musician and conductor reads the ad
isaac alexander isaacs menken uh he's on
tour in texas
sort of on tour his dad was a dry goods
manufacturer and alexander was probably
a traveling salesman telling people he
was a musician
a lot a little i mean i guess every we
still could play a tremendous amount if
right you could get away with it think
about the times in your life where
things were going shitty and you could
have just gone somewhere else and lied
yeah wait yeah yes
yeah so i'm sure tons of people are
doing it it's very appealing to just
yeah you can walk into a town and just
be like i'm a
doctor yeah so this is where i'll see
patients i need my gallbladder out yeah
great
jesus
i wanted my dad
get me the saw
and some lemon juice well whole lemons
okay here we go put the lemons inside
him like i'm supposed to oh my god then
you go to another town i'm an accountant
that way i'd like to put lemons in a guy
uh so
either way he reads her poem slash ad in
the paper and he writes to her and then
they meet in person and instant
connection i mean instant connection
it's but it's going to be an instant
connection when one person is putting an
ad in the paper and the other person's
like then i'll marry her
like with two people who are like
looking for this situation you know
they also are both performers sure
they're both ambitious
sort of he's a dry goods well okay
so they quickly got married in galveston
okay
right after the wedding ada started
working uh in supporting roles at the
liberty shakespeare theater
uh her name is now
aydah isaacs menken okay and that'll be
your name for good she's keeping that
one sure
then as alexander backed her she started
landing lead roles at the crescent
dramatic association of new orleans
an encyclopedia.com article quote hardly
a great actress the pretty somewhat
exotic looking young woman provided a
striking physical presence on stage
audiences received her well
so
not a good actress but hot hot so
i read a couple different this is when
being in the entertainment business and
your looks were it was like wow imagine
imagine a time where you're just judged
upon your appearance i can't imagine it
but that's what this was changed to
envision people didn't care as much
about the acting as the looks very
strange very weird
just feels like the entertainment would
be diminishing returns interesting yeah
you'd think so at some point yeah
unrelatable right when every main
character has a super high back
you know what i mean just every single
time is this place named [ __ ] town yeah
cause i want to [ __ ] everybody uh yeah i
mean what that really that should be
that would be a great movie
like hot town and you just put like an
ugly guy like a not even ugly a regular
regular guy yeah a human a human person
there just living amongst these tens who
were just it's just it is absurd yeah
like when zac efron
oh uh what's his name uh ted bundy oh
yeah
really this is
seriously
dude is that right i feel like we're not
like i get it he really wants to be a
good actor and god bless him come on but
this is not uh why you're here no or the
best one was what is the best one was
when ashton kutcher played steve jobs
when john just died and then they were
like you were like thinking like well at
some point they'll make a movie about
him and we'll find it he's like i
finished mine everyone's like what no
you're not the person no he's like i did
it first i was like no no no dude we
don't
want you to be doing it he's like yeah i
did it i'm steve jobs
i'm not kidding i don't remember the
last time i saw a movie as high as i saw
jobs in the theater
very quickly i was high as [ __ ] watching
jobs in the theater with three of my
buddies and we were just laughing we
were genuinely laughing like it was like
we were there seeing a different movie
and when it couldn't get more absurd
this one dude walks into a room and is
like hello
gareth and we were like what the [ __ ] is
going on
okay so yes all right so she's okay so
the paper review is basically like she's
not not a good actress but wow did
people like watching it yeah yowza
that's
there are some people like she was the
best actress of her time but like this
is the reality okay
yeah there's more of this
uh so
alexander just worships her she's into
him too they're really into each other
sure uh she uh converts to judaism or
she already was just i i love this again
i found different versions of where she
learned hebrew as a child and other ones
where she didn't so
i feel like she converted here okay um
she uh
so when she wasn't acting in a play then
she was writing articles in a paper
called israelite wow so she went she
went full on like now that's not like
that's not two words right it's not like
we don't get into the super dark
characters it's a israelite
for those of you who don't like all that
you want to read israel heavy that is
you're not ready for that no diet is
real it's an unbelievable magazine
um
yeah so she got into it she also wrote
she was also writing poems so in the
israelite articles she called on the
jewish people to defend themselves and
to prepare for the return of zion she
wrote an essay on jewish men being
allowed to sit in britain's parliament
yes a little scholars started quoting
her articles and their lectures she it
seems a little like it's a little fast
for the first person in the room to just
be like now we go to zion yeah yeah hey
hey
listen to one of these meetings before
no we're going i am now a jew let us
attack
hey pump the brakes over there a little
bit huh relax
we have been through too much ladies you
just lay you just yesterday i will not
be silenced like my people have been for
centuries
uh so
she wants more success and so they moved
to new york okay
she makes her stage debut there in march
1859 she had a small part but she wins
over audiences okay
she got more and more roles sometimes
plays close quickly and she'd have a dry
spell right
alexander does not want to be in new
york okay
he you didn't put that in your ad
i thought i knew you
[Laughter]
you have to follow the ad
willing to convert was what got me here
that's it open to conversion
so he wants to go back to his hometown
which is cincinnati
ada wants to be
you never hear that
don't you miss the bright lights
cincinnati
no sin city baby no no it's definitely
not since yes well they call it city
baby not at all they call it cincinnati
city it's called cincinnati sin city
baby it's just what can't happen in
cincinnati everything's open until 8 30.
cincinnati baby
[Music]
can i have a beer
sure
or wait no i don't know you know better
than me
no
yes yes no you can't okay yeah sorry
thank you there's no alcohol in sin city
no but you said it's in cities it is in
city a beer you can do anything you want
it's i know it's a tent but i would like
a beer it's too late drink from that
fountain sin city that's water we should
go to bed
it's a city it's eight fish
the neighbors in city think of the
neighbors this is terrible
let's do a puzzle with eye contact only
oh god i'm in city i'm so [ __ ] bored
yeah
that's not sensitive it's insane don't
do a song sin city baby take a ride i'm
dancing
uh so
yeah that's that's gonna be a problem
right
alexander actually wants the classic
stay-at-home wife
sure he wants her to make the meal i
like that he's bringing up now like he's
in new york and he's acting and he's
like you know i
rather if you weren't you now how is
this not a phase yeah now that you have
a man seems like you're really trying to
do stuff which i'm not loving
yeah he wants to just stay home have
kids make the meals you know the usual
you're a baby machine yes crank out the
babies and make them eat loaf
aida was not remotely interested in
being a housewife and that's why she'd
place the ad in the first place for
someone to take care of her while she
acts
in surprise that they didn't really get
to know each other super well through
her yeah i mean i found some people that
said they got married they got married
the next day so yeah i mean it seems
nothing um crazy there
in an article in liberty gazette ada
wrote that quote women should believe
there are other missions in the world
for them besides that of wife and mother
put that paper down diane what are you
reading
she clearly wrote it to alexander but it
publicly it's great though yeah she's
trolling him
things took a turn for the worse when
alexander lost all of his money in a bad
real estate investment and now he was
living off of ada's theater income you
know new york ain't that bad
babe
to make him feel better she named him as
her manager
okay wow okay
now audiences [ __ ] love her okay uh
and that meant men adoring her sure
they would crowd around the
stage door holding flowers to give her
okay wow and
she also started becoming more and more
flirtatious okay
alexander got very jealous
as your manager we should leave
don't touch his hand stop making out
with that man that's your manager i'm
your manager
and then aydah started wearing pants
i can't do this again dude i i i don't i
can't i can't i can't
i can't i just i've already had to do
this once
i don't want to
it's okay that she wore pants we really
need to well it upset alexander
now you're wearing pants and then she
started you've changed and then she
started smoking in public so you're
smoking you're wearing pants
when does it end aydah what next are you
gonna grow a dick
wearing pants and smoking
men smoked in public but it was unheard
of for a woman to do
she wrote her diary quote i i literally
can't process it i know it's crazy even
with the standards as they were as
whacked out as all that stuff was
i still there are elements of it where
i'm like i just can't i don't like i
don't know how it happened how did they
get to the point
even pants like i i don't get it but i'm
like okay
they weren't but smoking i know
in public yeah well men are smoking big
like what are you doing lady you're a
woman
just comfortably walking around like
what the [ __ ] is she doing
the whole thing's gonna fall apart if
you start smoking this is not a man in
pads but a lady
oh so she wrote her diary quote i have
told him i will leave him if he does not
stop badgering me with his sermons on
cigarettes i do not criticize him for
smoking i will not submit to the
dictation of any man yeah which i mean
yes which i think correct yes but he i
bet you what he's doing is he knows it's
ending
he's got to so he's doing this thing
where he's trying to be over controlling
but i know i also think like he at this
time
you meet a woman like this right she's
an actress she's doing things but you
think in your head well all she really
wants is to be married and then she'll
do what she's supposed to do which is
just have babies and stay home right i
think they all further and further away
yeah they all think that way and then he
marries her and she's not doing that
he's like wait no no no no i i a man i
gave you me now you make my baby we
can't both be wearing pants
[Applause]
are you crazy
uh so he took he couldn't take it
anymore and they separated in july okay
now she was getting poems published in
the clipper uh
newspaper for five bucks each
and one day she's at the paper's offices
and she meets california boxer johnny
bonisha boy heenan hey johnny banish a
boy heenan what's up he's from benicio
it's benicia benicio is a city in in
california okay that at one time for
like six months was the uh capital of
california before everybody was like oh
god this is benicia
it's a beneatha
uh he's 6-2 and over 200 pounds he has a
big black mustache he's very famous he's
a famous boxer right
johnny uh
proposed while asking her to abandon
acting and writing to concentrate on
being a wife and a mother that's a very
so he's like look i will marry you i
will marry you if you give up not a
proposal for marriage as much as a
contract betwixt yes
it's the best thing to be like give up
everything you love darling you have
changed me for the better yeah
yeah i agree i love you so much you're
wonderful i'm not down on one knee for a
reason yeah what oh my god will you make
me the happiest man in the world
and give up your career
and stop smoking in public and wear your
pants
and acquiesce to the system in the world
that i deem appropriate and the fit into
my life completely and have none of your
own thoughts or
uh
artistic creative developments hold on
hold on this is all the places yeah
because i mean all of us usually people
i mean all of it i mean all of it you
will wait on me hand and foot okay
whatever i want will be brought to me on
a tray
i will eat on the tray mainly but if i
don't want to eat on the tray and i'd
rather you get down and i eat off your
back that's also a possibility
every day i look into your eyes i know
there's something special about you oh
and it's your it's your malleability
you're so open to change which is why
the idea that if potentially you don't
get to go in every room in the house we
share that's not going to strike you as
crazy so i take your hand i take your
hand shut up
i'm serious shut up
i take your hand and i ask you i ask you
as i put the ring on
will you marry me just say yes and it's
legally binding no also you'll make my
clothes oh so i get massages whenever
and now you have to pee standing up i
don't want any of those toilet seats in
my hand say yes
i love you baby yeah we're doing it oh
my lord i got a maid that wife sorry
okay but somehow she agrees
but she just went through this i know
she's like with you you have a mustache
she must have really been into him sure
i guess but yeah all right but they got
married secretly on september 3rd 1859.
it didn't take long for the secret to
get out sure
now
johnny taught ada to box on their
honeymoon great
good
but not in pants that's the best
put on your dress we're going boxing
come on uh he was a drinker and uh a
carouser this is gonna be good this is
gonna be good uh
he did not spend much time with his wife
oh
weird uh there were rumors of abuse
and they were very prevalent at the time
but we have no proof but i'm assuming if
there were rumors
he's a boxer yeah it's true i look i
think you're right and isn't until
proven guilty uh yeah this one i'm ready
i'm ready
um
she said he was jealous of the adoration
from her fans and that she made more
money than him
and then alexander showed up in new york
and announced that he and ada weren't
divorced yet
this i mean i i've moved on from this
guy
she said she thought he had divorced her
but he hadn't i didn't i couldn't afford
it
can i buy 30
but he now begins to he now begins
divorce proceedings but you know the
public is like it's a scandal right
right how dare she uh johnny meanwhile
hops on when he learns this he hops on a
ship and goes to london to fight in the
world heavyweight championship against
uh champ tom sayers okay so he just
bailed he's like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
um the fight lasted 37 rounds jesus
christ
what until one man died of natural
causes
johnny uh was beating him
well
and the promoters were so concerned he
was going to kill sayers that they
stopped the fight and called it a draw
at 37 rounds
so they were just like watching an
execution and they're like yeah let's
call it we're good this man's out of
blood
but he still made a lot of money from
the fight he had also left the 50 count
back then didn't help anything no it
didn't at all 34.
35.
36.
is this my eye 44
47.
he's up he's up he's ready to go all
right i'll be live smell this smell this
there you go buddy oh what is that [ __ ]
oh boy he's getting his brains bashed
manure
oh god two
uh
some member he had left ada to deal with
the scandal uh she was also pregnant
okay good good good good uh while he was
gone she gave birth to their son who
died soon after expected which is i mean
not the death part but that is what he
wanted like she was doing what he had
asked that is true so except for the big
still being married part yeah i mean i
guess yeah that is a big part but he
didn't know he's a drunk yeah right yeah
he's also been hit in the head a bunch
yeah right
uh when johnny came back into new york
in july he'd have no he had nothing to
do with her okay
some said some people said she only
married him to increase her fame
okay
uh and then aydah divorced john
and
right after that her mother died so
she's super depressed she's had a
[ __ ] run of luck that's just terrible
and alexander that one's over they're
divorced too yeah they found me that's
right it's all wrapped up yeah like i
gotta divorce him then i'll divorce you
so in august 1860 aydah was the lowest
point in her life in her career the new
york sunday mercury published her
despair poems wow so it's like tick-tock
yeah right where girls just go on there
and show videos of them crying or i mean
or just twitter where someone will be
like you really can't bother with today
and you're like yeah finn finn shows me
videos all the time it's like oh look
this girl just broke up with her
boyfriend and they they do crying videos
no i know they're just really stop that
it's i mean i don't even think it's just
i mean i've definitely seen a lot of
there's a the
filming yourself for
sympathy is like a thing where i'm like
it actually makes it's gutting because
it's like oh my god you're not gonna get
the not only the attention you want but
like it's not you're not gonna oh no the
face you will regret this to some extent
it shows me the comments and they're
like oh you're so emo and i'm just like
jesus christ man
the internet is not the place to go to
look for sympathy no
uh
so
comment section especially
right so she's doing comment section is
what makes you do the crying video
that's right so she does her despair
poems
and a critic called them quote more
self-revealing than those which any
other female american poet had ever
dared to publish okay
she couldn't bring herself to work until
early 1861
all of her troubles though had only
increased her fame i thought that was
gonna be a character all of her troubles
i was like
all right hello
just comes out of a cloud of smoke i
heard you've got some trouble well you
called all of the trouble now all of
your trouble's over you're probably not
gonna want me around which would you
rather your trouble be over or all of it
be your trouble
dodger
um
so
right so but it increases her fame
right
so she
realizes that
uh and then she vows to quote never
again be a victim or sacrifice anything
for the male dominated society
she returns to the stage in mazzepa i
love that show and in that she would
play a boy okay
the final scene
in this play
the boy is stripped of his clothes
lashed
on the back of a horse ridden up to
cliffs and then disappears in the clouds
how big is the stick well they would
build this we're doing it in montana
they would build the staircase and the
horse would go up the stairs poor horse
i can only imagine the abysmal treatment
i'm a theater horse i'm sorry i'll be
doing what i'm actually two man named
dan
do i not have lines do i just go up
these [ __ ] stairs what do you mean i
can't wear pants
i'm a horse
[Music]
usually the production would put a dummy
on an old horse and and it would walk up
the stairs okay
but ada and her manager had another idea
okay
she would ride the horse up the stairs
so
they'd put her on a horse oh boy dressed
right remember the boys yeah she's
topless right oh he's topless
yeah they take out they strip him and
then they lash him i mean it's
essentially naked yeah okay so okay
dressed in skin colored tights so she
would appear naked okay
since she was a playing a boy it wasn't
the same as if she was portraying a
naked woman
right because naked women couldn't
appear on the stage but since she was a
boy
then that gave it a pass i love these
again this is the dumbest thing ever
well it's just like with the culture of
the men back then their dumb rules like
get they're like you're not allowed to
see a naked woman and they're like wait
wait hold hold on it feels like we went
a little far no consistency is what
we're preaching here yeah i'm just
saying though like maybe it's equal with
nudity of course it can't be that's
crazy you can't have a nude woman will
allow men to only be nude yeah but i
feel like let's let nobody be nude what
are you talking about that's insane of
course a man can be nude so we're only
allowing dicks to be seen all right now
that's how you create a society that's
perfect for our vision
it it look there's zero
it makes zero sense well if she's
dressed as a man as a woman and she's
naked as a man
that we can do
that's legal
that's legal that's exactly what to say
so it opens on july 3 1861 in albany
it's a packed house
she cut her hair short like a boy sure
the audience couldn't tell if she was
naked or not but they were shocked and
excited as she rode through the crowd so
she must taken stairs through the crowd
at the end
jesus
she got crazy standing ovations every
night okay and overnight she became a
huge name wow
and then the play opens on broadway
this was the year the civil war broke
out and she was like a bright spot in
this dark nightmarish tour
the new york post quote she is so lovely
that she numbs the mind and the senses
real i mean is this a story about how
the post has changed
i give the show full bonus yeah i mean
honestly i mean it's just a dude going
[ __ ] she is hot what was the play about
she's hot
did you hear me
i don't know what the play is about
she's [ __ ] hot what's the play about
the plays about it at 90 minutes
with a great ending
new yorkers packed the theater she was
known as quote the naked lady
you know it felt for a minute like
there was
some real
maybe change like like something had
changed you know like she was like wow
she's finally
this
human but it's like she's not a human
she's the naked lady
like the naked cowboy in times square
it's like you're like him but on a horse
yeah yeah okay
victor hippard of the new york sentinel
uh he's a critic he wrote quote she
glosses my face with laughter and tears
she is the aphrodite of a male world the
male world has waited for imagine she is
a rare beauty perched upon one of
heaven's high heels of light i just like
i've seen a naked woman gentleman his
wife reading that did you write this
let's
just i'm gonna close my eyes and [ __ ]
you
put this article on your face
it's amazing to be like it's this is so
embarrassing for men like they just
losing their [ __ ] minds and writing
like there's a publisher who's like
we'll go with it front page
let me tell you about a boner i
experienced
oh god uh soon adam hey some people told
me she was on a horse but i hadn't
noticed
soon ada was making 500 a week okay
which is a shitload she
buys a big house
uh which became
a center for new york intellectuals so
now all of the
writers and the actors and all the you
know it's one of right it's a social
it's like a she's this place for people
of the time yes right
the editor of the mercury said quote she
could discourse fluently on matters
pertaining to literature as well as the
sciences and the latest news of the
world i don't want you to freak out but
behind this woman is actually some
conversation that you'd enjoy i've
discovered woman can talk this lady not
like others she have thoughts that we
like to digest makes sense she know what
moon is she no moon we like moon we like
her
[Laughter]
she became good friends with walt
whitman and uh fitz james o'brien
so the play goes on tour sometimes she
would make uh
she sometimes she would get cat calls
because she was from the south because
the civil war is on right like people be
like you know maybe she probably had an
accent i would assume what do you mean
cat call it like
saying just it's derogatory [ __ ] oh i
thought isn't catcall more like a
salacious sort of uh i i you know what
it this article said cat calls and i
looked it up and it says sometimes it's
just demeaning also so yeah i think our
version of it's different but that's
yeah both i mean
both wildly appropriate at any point to
just shout at a stranger as they walk by
you
you know i mean
hey i like your tits you southern
monsters i mean the idea that they would
just yeah it is crazy
yeah cat calls are weird but i've seen
i mean
new york construction workers are
amazing at cat calls they don't do it
anymore though yeah of course they do
they do yeah i believe so i mean yeah i
don't think they've stopped i don't know
maybe some that's probably why the city
is always under construction well done
thank you
uh
so
when she made some pro-secession remarks
she was almost arrested in maryland
but
this all increases ticket sales
because and she's probably doing this
with that in mind now because she's
become very good at keeping herself
constantly in the public eye she's she's
kim kardashian in a way she knows that
anything she's trending yes anything she
does
she uh marries the editor of the mercury
the one who said oh she she understands
sciences and and she can talk like that
right robert henry newell they get
married
he had been convinced they would end up
together after reading her poems and
watching her acting he said she had the
keenest mind he had quote ever
encountered in a member of her sex
it really didn't feel like it was gonna
get there but oh my god you're so smart
for a woman you are still perfect
sometimes i feel like i'm almost talking
to a man if i close my eyes
sometimes i forget you're just beneath
me
[Laughter]
the owner of the opera house in san
francisco offered ada 1500 a week for 12
weeks
okay
that's 32 000 a week today it's decent
yeah
as uh
as we learned previously in a previous
episode san francisco is theater crazy
right
there are uh lots of rich people and
then there's lots of wannabe minors uh
lots of dudes lot of dudes right
men of the frontier uh
were already drooling over ada knowing
about her
it's very strange she's beautiful she
has an amazing body she also uh she also
has come to understand the value of
photography for publicity okay
so playbills with her picture on the
front would appear in a town before she
arrived so
oh right she's advertising she's showing
the uh a picture of her
i mean they're like little shorty shorts
and like you know revealing tops right
and they'd be in every paper and they'd
be placed in every theater so people see
oh hot lady gonna be here right
she's [ __ ] smart nobody told me this
was a play
i thought she was gonna stand there and
not talk oh [ __ ] i guess we got a little
newer jabber jabber everywhere
so they set sail her excuse me when do
you get naked pardon for sorry i'll sit
down sorry
so awkward why are you talking with
clothes on this is not what i ordered
would it help if some of us men got
naked
no okay one of us already has
frank
sorry
drop the gun
yeah i'll say
can't find my belt okay can we get the
house lights up no
no
dropped a bunch of no house lights
dropped a lot of change
is there a bag i could have made what is
the thing where they put on marathon
runners the foil just can you leave
i mean i'd love to get my pants
this is a pickle
i'm in the situation oh boy lol look at
everyone looking at me sorry you keep
going i'll find them
i'd love to get them before we start i'd
just love to get them yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right okay yeah sure
you uh should not go outside well
let's let's start again okay start over
good
so they set sail for san francisco on
july 13th 1863 they go through the
panama jungle
because that's there's no panama
there's no panama canal so the way that
you would do it is you would sail down
to panama and then cross the [ __ ]
face well we have to go through the
panamanian jungle obviously we're headed
to san fran
you know how it is
the kids didn't make it they were killed
by jaguars
so the trip really harmed their marriage
and it never really recovered at some
point uh he insisted
aydah give up
her stage career telling her she should
read and write only poetry in her spare
time and she should focus on being a
wife i really feel like maybe dating for
a little while would be a good idea like
a year two years she's gonna make 32 000
a [ __ ] week in our money and he's
like you shouldn't do this write poetry
by the time they arrived in san
francisco the theater owner had done a
ton of pr the entire run was sold out
opening night i mean look this obviously
isn't going anywhere
give it up hang it up lord read the room
shouldn't you be cooking come on
opening night august 24th 1863 san
francisco's elite packed maguire's opera
house
ladies are wearing diamonds and furs the
the gentleman had capes and silk and
silk hats i'm going as an x-men tonight
we're all going to see the naked woman
uh is an opening night such as the city
had never seen
one thousand seats filled it was rumored
she played
the part in the nude so they think she's
gonna be totally nude
oh oh okay sorry okay i thought you
meant she had done it uh the next day
critics claimed quote prudery is
obsolete now
wait prudery so they're into it yeah
they're like that's it that's just game
over game over there's no more approved
right
i thought because it was rumored she was
naked they were like well it's
disappointing she's not fully nude she's
still in their eyes like right basically
yes this is escalating
uh she got rave reviews
taking on men's roles were very daring
for the time especially when you wore
almost nothing right
audiences just go bug [ __ ] over the
naked lady okay she was also in other
plays while there she hung out with the
best authors again like she's again
right right in the mix because even
though she's not a great actress she's
i think writers are like she's [ __ ]
taking a chance she's doing something
there's there's there's like an artistic
skew to it
a clear empowerment like thing where
she's like okay so i'll [ __ ]
i'll use my sexuality and look at you
idiots yeah right right
um well and are the are the women
equally into it of the time or is it
like half a room of men like stand up
barbara come on show some respect that
was unbelievable there's nobody better
than her boy oh boy can you imagine a
woman doing something like that i know
you couldn't darling come on stand up
for her look at her she's amazing god do
you think if i got two of you i could
trade it i know i don't want to say that
i'm gonna rush the stage i'm getting a
divorce i can't handle you
i couldn't find anything about the
women's response but there's a couple
negative there's a little bit of
negative stuff but
i'm sure the women did not enjoy it for
the time yeah well i think going with
your if all the men are like losing
their minds you're like all right frank
yeah
so uh what you got on the horse last
night
yes you've asked me a few times that was
definitely the best part honey we're
buying a horse that was definitely the
best part what was your favorite part of
the horse
great good
mine was the lady on the horse oh
you know some people say there was a
show before the poorest part so crazy
we're not together anymore oh man
it's such a good show we should go again
no
halloween let's go no let's not let's
the hugo is her no and i'll go was the
horse no
[Music]
remember when she was on the horse no
naked no at the show no was that last
night or two nights ago
it was like an eternity wow that's all i
think about i know
a toast
to that time she was on the horse and
she was totally naked the best part of
everyone's life cheers ding oh man
hmm that's good all right i'm gonna go
to bed and hope i dream about it have a
good night honey
i sleep with you in a bed
hi there she's remember she's on the
horse
no no she don't remember i hate my wife
i wish i was with her oh that happened
again baby whoo that awful nightmare
huh
god should we go to the show
no uh
only they did him during the day
remember that when she got on that horse
[Laughter]
all right i'm going to turn in i've been
up for an hour
[Laughter]
uh so
yeah the people are going [ __ ] crazy
for it um
there are
a lot of rumors that she's having
affairs with millionaires in the city
okay which she wrote about them in her
diary okay so rumors may be true yeah uh
none of this helped her third marriage
which fell apart and newell returned to
new york city right
80 aydah now publicly acknowledged she
was not good at picking husbands but the
marriages had given her new view of the
role of women
quote a man discovered america but a
woman equipped the voyage so everywhere
a man executes the performance but woman
trains the man will men ever learn to be
grateful
well i mean aside from a man discovering
america it's pretty good
the theater owner asked aydah to remove
even more clothing hey uh we got some
notes
from the union um they was wondering if
maybe a nipple could pop out is that
crazy yeah yeah
say no but we was just getting some
notes from the uh
studio studio i know it's all sold out
but what if uh what is he thinking maybe
you show a little b crack
maybe a little bit it's just nothing if
you don't want to it's fine we're just
saying you know everybody loves the show
but some people are thinking the one
notice could we see a little b crack
more more is it crazy to get a little
bit cranky
and maybe a quarter
as the character yeah i think it's all
okay it's all within it's within the
character i think this guy would show
his bee crack a little more i think so
as a boy a boy you want to see more talk
wardrobe about adjusting the b crack i j
i just want to ask a question
is
is it a boy if we don't see the nipples
yeah that's that's true
yeah so we'll leave you a good show good
to talk
good show maybe cut a little beatrix i'm
gonna go into the closet and just leave
it a crack open there we go and you go
ahead and get dressed
so uh
he agrees to increase her salary and she
agrees to wear only a blouse and shorts
that revealed most of her legs okay
it was incredibly scandalous for the
time people are now literally fighting
to get tickets jesus christ an
organization known as the reform group
complained quote her style belonged more
to the wild old time of 49ers than to a
respectable society where many days
often pass without any murders at all
what are they even talking
well so 49ers it's 20 years before and
everyone's like
just bat [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy yeah but
it's all dudes it's fighting and right
and they're lawless and they're saying
this is what it was like then right okay
there's a naked woman here so clearly
that's the same as murder yeah right
but she's making tons of money the
theater's making money the crowds are
[ __ ] loving it so now no one gives a
[ __ ] about the reform group right
she became known as the frenzy of frisco
wow
and they adopted her as their favorite
daughter
the saint francis hook and ladder
company made her an ordinary honorary
member you're a ladder
you're a fireman you're now a ladder
uh she was given a beautiful belt by
them and the entire brigade including a
brass band championship serenaded her
all the firemen serenaded her oh my god
hey
[Music]
how embarrassing are we
uh so the civil war is on
uh ada hung a big confederate flag
across the wallet or hotel room great
again that's gonna get great it's gonna
get press right oh right
during the day she walked the streets
dressed in a single yellow silk garment
what journalists were constantly writing
about her when writer joaquin miller
came to her hotel room for an interview
she was lying upon a yellow rug wearing
a yellow sheath
okay so she
i mean really at this point is it she's
just realized the power of manipulating
a level where she's like neo in the
matrix she she yes she realizes how easy
it is to be slightly sexual and men go
[ __ ] right and media goes insane they
go insane right
she wrote quote i'm dressing like a
sponge now
he wrote quote i doubt if any other
woman in the world could wear a dress
like that in the winds of san francisco
and not look ridiculous
but this one
this one i tell you she look woman
she look woman
and what's the confederate flag that's
just again to just be controversial yes
100 okay
aidan now headed east over land she did
chose to go through the jungle she did
shows in virginia city
the gold hill news quote she has come oh
my lord
i mean honestly
[Laughter]
woman here
she has come she's decidedly a pretty
woman and judging her style we
suppose she does not care how she rides
she was on the front seats with her back
turned to the horses
well [ __ ] it's madness this woman oh my
god she has no cares
she has come like jesus is walking
through parted clouds from the sky the
woman who wears badly anything is here i
mean that's why i just can't picture
being married to one of the who's like
oh baby and the place finally we get to
see her
we're finally getting
i've been waiting for purpose
what happened but it kicked me hug me
baby oh my god
oh
i will kill someone to go see it there's
nothing matters more to me than this
oh
i mean it's really [ __ ] insane it's
nuts this reminds me it's like girl
watching and it's exactly like watching
it's this is it's just except this
person is like figuring out ways to kind
of modulate yeah she right girl watching
that as a song she was more of a yeah
that was like a
that was a shock victim right that was
crazy
this is a woman using yeah using her she
understands what she's doing right
[ __ ] good for her like she's like
right you sketch it yeah hey she thinks
they're all idiots my guess is now she
can wear pants yeah so and smoke in
public
hundreds are turned away at the door in
virginia city
people stood in the packed in the aisles
uh the male miners couldn't believe what
they were seeing
encyclopedia.com quote estimates place
the value of gifts and payments of
silver and shares of stock
at a hundred thousand or more so they
were just giving her [ __ ] wow
although that could be exaggerated but
you know also
probably true yeah when she left
virginia city i got you under my teeth
when she left virginia city miners
gifted her a silver brick valued at
403.31 it was stamped
miss ada isaac's menken from friends of
virginia city nevada territory my kids
ain't eating in a while but
me and the fellas put in a bunch we
thought we'd get you this silver brick
here
i wish had there's no uh well we don't
have food or nothing but we don't need
it and we don't want anymore haven't
seen you up there in that idea outfit it
made us tell you man you don't need
friends i am nourished i'm nourished we
are full we are actually physically we
are starving physically we are starving
and our bones are widdle but uh oh my
god we we uh we we we are we are we are
just so happy so as we uh some of us
have actually died during the play
because it took us so long to save up
but we wanted you to have this yeah
thank you so much
yeah sex brick yeah so please thank you
so much sorry sorry i meant silver
bricks i said sex break shut up dan
all right well we live in we don't have
homes we sold them for them we'll see
you later bye baby goodbye miss
you
that was worth it oh my god she's so
normal i almost i like sleeping
yeah she's down to earth i've never seen
one before except my wife but this one
so uh
they also named a mine after her and
formed the menken shaft and tunnel
company this here's the adahol stock
certificates had a picture of a naked
lady bound to a galloping stallion it's
a i i a homage to your the time you was
naked on a horse which is something we
just are unable to forget
so when she got back to new york city
she was loaded
but the east coast wasn't the west coast
during the war easterners were worn down
by four years of fighting
they didn't want to go out to shows
so aydah got an offer to come to london
and off she went on in april 1864.
mazepa and the naked lady opened on
october 3rd
there had been a lot of discussion in
london papers over whether or not
audiences would like it but i mentioned
a naked lady right yeah yeah yeah so uh
they went ape [ __ ] okay for sure she
received 12 curtain calls on opening
night that's
honest to god that can't be you at what
point like after three you're like i'm
not going out there again
uh they're they're beating each other up
fine one more
that that's it i'm capping it at nine
well
unfortunately the man is strung up and
they said that they will take his life
unless there's another curt for god's
sake
they don't even need the other cast
members to come out anymore for the
curtain call
a critic quote the most popular of
american actresses has conquered us
once again the top writers became her
friends poet algenon uh charles
swinburne wrote the poem a law awareness
for her she would next perform in the
play children of the sun there but
ticket sales dropped off interesting so
after six weeks she did mazeppa again
so she was like i mean
obviously like this is like she's
typecast
yeah pretty much i mean they just want
to see her in the tight outfit yeah so
she said she wants to she tries acting
just acting acting and they're like
man something was different that's not
naked enough it was weird
um her marriage with newell was
officially over in
1865. they got into new old right annual
that's correct
uh she she uh went on an american tour
again in 1866 and did well
and then she met and married james paul
barkley jesus not much is known about
him other than he was rich okay the
reason not much is known is because
three days after the marriage
a pregnant ada sailed off to europe and
never saw him again interesting how did
you get pregnant so fast
we haven't even had sex
yeah bye
oh this is like jesus bye see you soon i
love you baby
well she was just using him to cover for
the pregnancy um
so that she could say i'm married
have a kid
she went to paris where she had the baby
okay the son was named louis
dude
victor emmanuel barkley so she was like
well i've been in paris for a day it's a
french baby that's right
she wasn't there to perform mazeppa but
the play the pirates of the savannah
audiences and critics loved it equally
sold out shows
and
she was constantly in revealing clothes
in the play right
artists and writers once again formed
her circle
and while there she also had a very
close relationship with novelist adamine
aurora luz dupi
who went by the pseudonym george sand
cool
my last name would be sand
sand was the godmother to ada's son
by the time the show closed ada was now
one of the biggest celebrities in the
global north wow so she's now huge
everywhere
newspapers and magazines wrote about
every move she made rumors whether true
or false just increased her fame
but it wasn't enough she wanted more
she believed if she published her best
poems it would lead to true immortality
what she wants
she wants to be forever known and she
thinks that she writes that's not true
immortality what is her as an artist
right she wants her work to live on
forever yes she doesn't want to be like
i am immortal
i'm 500 000 years old if you write good
bombs you never die do you want to see
the play again
ada
old david i'm ada from the mountain
uh so she starts working on her
collection of poems called uh in felicia
now she's not the best actress her fam
on the stage was you know from being
naked mostly
and the ability to keep her name in the
papers constantly but she's a good poet
okay
critics praised many of them although
the technique isn't great
um as she was waiting for the book to be
published she headed for london
and opened pirates there but nobody
cared
some said she was lacking energy
uh she probably was not well she
returned to paris and began rehearsing a
new play
it turns out that previously during a
performance the horse had ran too close
to a flat on the stage
and her leg was badly cut okay
on june 9th she collapsed on stage
she spent
the next month in bed and doctors had no
idea what was wrong but they told her
she would make a full recovery
okay
good
on august 10th she died
she was 33. holy [ __ ] the cut had led to
a cancerous cancerous growth and she had
advanced tuberculosis wow
she was buried in a cemetery but then
later moved to a jewish cemetery the
next year
george's son
george sand had her son secretly adopted
by wealthy parents and no one knows
who to this day wow
eight days later she died um eight days
after she died her collection of poems
in felicia was published it was
dedicated to charles dickens who
believed she had the heart and brain of
a great poet aydah menken's success in
california theaters was not matched
until films became popular
she was appreciated around the world but
never felt more loved by an audience as
she was when she performed in california
and nevada
that's crazy it's it's also crazy like i
was thinking of this with because i got
bitten by a pig
and on a farm
and i was like you can't just say that i
was bitten by a pig on a farm within the
last eight days well that's not a normal
thing for a human being shut up and let
me tell you my story that's irrelevant
about when a pig bit my hand
and burgundy blood poured from it
how many how many
puncture marks is it one it's just this
just one it's this one and blood's
pouring out of your hand pouring out of
my hand pig apologizing the pig is the
pig never was an attack the pig was just
trying to eat a lot and i understand
that um
but i was like when i was at the rapid
care and you know you're in the back and
like they're like they want to do all
this stuff and i'm going i don't need
all this the guy's like listen if this
hit your bone i mean it was just it
really dawned on me like how i was being
the worst because i'm like i don't need
all the medical care it's like no you
would die from cuts like you could get
cut and you would die
before antibiotics you would just be
like well that's it your life's over you
cut it on this rusty thing like that
your life's over it's over
um
but that is crazy i mean
it is it is really weird how in order to
kind of
i guess sort of fool
the
men who are in charge you almost have to
like hack their rules which she
basically did she did she like
figured out the way that you still were
you know it i mean first of all the idea
that she's basically naked and people
are like at least it's not pants like
it's very strange uh yeah it's the crazy
but so she kind of found this route in a
way that she was able to kind of carve
out
you know she manipulated it
she had
yeah right and she hacks the minds of
the men who are like the ones who are
i mean essentially
it's like pavlov's dogs like
the men
are
are so
like everyone everything it's it's
sexually sexually repressed right yeah
everything so the so no one can see this
stuff except your your wife at home
right
like it's like it's like there was a
balloon and she just popped it and they
all just [ __ ] lost their minds like
they could not believe what was
happening right
but then again also it's like then if
she's wearing pants then people are like
well that's okay to wear pants well then
that's the crazy part yeah you're normal
yeah because you can do it she found
that you can
she found a loophole right you could do
it on stage she was like oh they're
monkeys they're totally they are monkey
but if she walked around outside like
that yeah they would be
yeah right it's it's so [ __ ] it's
weird but it's i mean jesus christ still
very much
you know relevant and prevalent
many different ways today obviously yeah
um wow
sourcesencyclopedia.com you never
mentioned excited that's right and uh
chris ennis
book entertaining women actresses
dancers and singers in the old west
yeah man i mean look
dudes are [ __ ] up
yeah dudes are [ __ ] up yeah it really
is strange that there's still basically
a monopoly on i mean on white dudes
being in charge at some point you would
think that we would
we should self topple you know like i
think we are i mean we are for sure but
it's still like it would have been nice
if you know it didn't have to be this
way it's just yeah but look people
always say if women were in charge you'd
be a lot better but you know i always
think like well how's margaret thatcher
like the best the thing about the thing
about our society and
particularly capitalism is it allows
psychopaths to rise to power and so
you're just going to get women's
psychopaths i mean also if someone dies
it's like they're they're absolved it
keeps happening oh like with colin
powell ronald reagan died
[ __ ] monster by the way i love i
guarantee you right now he's getting
he's getting one pound but i guarantee
you right now so i'm like hey i got
through it without [ __ ] being too
political
yeah also [ __ ] turn it off if you
don't want to hear our dumb leftist
opinions when the show's over [ __ ]
turn it off at the end yeah just stop it
the story's over but no it's true it
doesn't matter who you are you die and
you're the you're you're back i mean it
is it is a it is an incredibly dangerous
part of our society that
if you wore a military uniform you can
literally do whatever in the [ __ ] you
want the
you can be the worst human beings and
they're like yeah but he sacrificed so
much no did he did he yeah i don't know
well yeah it's also i think you know
yeah when you place
when you when lives have different value
uh put on them that's a problem when you
say
one for one you know one for a hundred
is the same it's like i don't think that
i don't know how you kind of get that do
you know what math is yeah
um
uh yeah all right december 16th
momenthouse.com
san diego december 10th 10th
join us